hey you guys
flickers of fear movie review time once
again
the one we're talking about today is a
fairly new film
that just arrived on shutter probably
maybe like a week or two ago
and i had a couple people that either i
don't know if they had seen it and they
recommended it to me or said this looks
like it's you know something in your
wheelhouse so probably you should check
it out
so i decided a couple days ago that i
was going to check it out so
this movie came out in 2020 and
is called an unquiet grave as far as i
could determine
this was the feature debut of the
director terence cray who was also the
co-writer
now it was also co-written by christine
nyland who also stars
in this movie i'm gonna say from the
outset i actually quite liked this movie
i can see like it doesn't have a huge
amount of reviews on imdb because like i
said it just kind of came out of nowhere
and appeared on shutter
because they picked it up and i feel
like uh
opinions are kind of divided it's like
i've seen a couple of reviews there's
not a ton but there's a couple of
reviews like you know
this is a fairly decent more like a
psychological
uh thriller it's very micro budget but
they do a lot with what they have
but then there's kind of like another
half of people that said it was really
boring and nothing happens and blah blah
so it's one of those type of movies
just keep in mind that there are a grand
total of two people
in this movie two actors uh christine
nyland who plays
two parts and jacob a ware who just
plays one part
and there are no other people in the
movie at all keep that in mind watching
it's it's
not a long movie it's only about an hour
12 minutes hour 15 minutes
and it's very laser focused on its
one concept this one review that i was
watching
actually he said kind of an insightful
thing and he actually quite liked this
movie
he said this is almost like a long
short film in the sense that it's not
this big sprawling epic story with
subplots and all these different
characters and everything
it's just very very focused on this on
these two characters and on this one
situation
and so in that way it comes across
almost like a short film
even though technically it's almost
feature length long
so as i said you know just know all this
going into it uh you know that said
i actually quite uh enjoyed this movie i
thought it was very atmospheric very
creepy like i said it's very very micro
budget you can tell but
they did a lot with uh with what they
had
now if you don't want to know anything
about this movie and like i said i i
prefer to go into movies not really
knowing what they're about or where
they're going
um and i know some people are like that
too so if you don't really want to know
anything i'm not going to spoil
anything really because this is pretty
new and shutter just added it so i want
to give people a chance to watch it
but as i said before it's kind of hard
to talk about a movie if you can't talk
about anything that happens in it so
you know if so if you don't want it to
know anything about the movie just go
into it completely blind
then maybe watch this later because i'm
going to talk a little bit about what
happens in it this movie actually kind
of reminded me
of the concept of pet cemetery sort of
also kind of reminded me a little bit of
a dark song
if you guys saw that with uh that was
just about like the occult guy and
the woman and they you know were doing
the long ritual and it was just like the
two of them
kind of reminded me of that and it gave
me a little bit of a vibe
of another one that we watched on
shutter not too long ago what the hell
was it called i think it was called
after midnight uh about the guy and his
wife disappears and then he thinks that
there's a monster outside
uh this one kind of gave me that sort of
vibe as well so if any of that
sounds like you know cool to you then
probably you will enjoy this one as well
but like i said it's not a big action
movie it's more like a
it's almost more like a character study
or like a psychological study
even though there is like a little bit
of gore and there is like supernatural
[ __ ]
but it's that type of thing more so what
you got at the very beginning
you have a guy named jamie played by
jacob aware
now his wife has died in a car accident
like a year prior
and he's still not really getting over
it so
he's standing at the uh his wife's grave
and
then you have christine nyland playing
ava who is his sister-in-law
now ava was the twin sister of
jaime's wife whose name was julie or
jules
so they're both at the grave kind of
talking and
it comes to pass that they have decided
and i guess they've been talking about
this before
there's a lot of things that are sort of
unspoken or like
left not left to the viewers imagination
really but there's a lot of stuff that's
kind of
i don't want to say cryptic because
that's going a little too far but they
don't really
spoon feed you a lot of information like
a lot of stuff is kind of like
you have to infer things from the
conversations that they have
so also know that going in this is one
you kind of have to pay
there's not a ton a ton of dialogue but
you do kind of have to pay attention to
everything that's said because
everything in here like
infers something about what the larger
thing that this thing is that's going on
well
so they're talking so they finally
decide and i guess they've been going
back and forth
with this for a while that they're going
to do
some sort of ritual that ostensibly
will bring julie back from the dead
now jamie apparently has been in contact
with
a guy who knows how to do it and
apparently did it
with his son like brought his son back
you don't ever see this person i think
the only time he ever talks
like he's talking on the phone with him
like at one point but you don't hear his
voice or anything
it's like i said there's just two people
in this movie and that's it there's more
than two characters but there's only two
actors in this movie is what i meant to
say
so they've decided they're gonna do this
ritual to bring iraq bring her back from
the dead which is
kind of i think why it reminds started
reminding me of a dark song at that
point
so the two of them go out to this spot
in the woods
because i guess you have to do the
ritual on the exact spot where the
person
died so i guess she was in a car
accident it was you know when he was
driving so i guess there's some guilt
there
and she was thrown from the car so they
find the spot
in the woods now i don't really want to
spoil too much
from this point but i will say
that yes jamie did want to do the ritual
to bring
julie back from the dead and yes ava
agreed to it
and they start doing the ritual but i
will say that jamie wasn't entirely
honest
about what exactly this ritual entailed
maybe you can use your imagination but
that's kind of as far as i want to go
with it because like i said i don't
you know i want to talk about a little
bit but i didn't really want to like
spoil any of it because i think it's
better like when you don't really know
where it's going
so i will say that the ritual
works because obviously there wouldn't
be a movie if it didn't
and from there you get a very strange
i don't know it's just like this really
kind of creepy it's very very low key
it's very very it's very low budget
but it's pretty much all
atmosphere and all concept but
that said i've i don't know i found it
like really kind of intriguing i really
liked those two actors are like really
really good
they've been in some other stuff too
because they looked kind of familiar
uh i think jacob ware has done like a
lot of tv
and uh and whatnot i think christine
island has been on some stuff too
because she looks super familiar also
uh but the two of them i mean for being
the only two in the movie and
you know this is maybe a little bit of a
spoiler but christine nyland plays
you know both twins so she knows she has
a dual role and you can actually tell
when she's being one or the other you
know what i mean she's she's very good
at like
differentiating like the two women which
i thought was really good
but for a movie this intimate
that's the word that i want to use for
it it's a very intimate almost a
claustrophobic type of movie because
you're just
laser focused on these two characters
and this ritual to bring this woman back
from the dead
and what ensues from that
i don't want to like you know say oh
this is like
a brilliant or it's like the best movie
ever but
it was actually really i really liked
the atmosphere of it it was like had
some kind of creepy
imagery uh there's one particular thing
like with the gravestone that i really i
liked that i thought that was like a
creepy
aspect that you don't really see in a
lot of movies uh so i kind of liked that
and there was one shot of like you know
one of them like standing far away and
that's like that always creeps me out
like in the woods or whatever
so it's like that kind of stuff is
creepy um i think a lot of people didn't
like
the end because the ending
is very abrupt and
you're kind of not entirely sure and
actually i'm not entirely sure
what the implication was i mean i think
i know but i'm not really sure
so there was that about it but this does
seem to be
most of the reviews i saw i saw one
review of it that was
like pretty positive and there he's like
you know it's not the best movie ever
made but it's like a decent like an
enjoyable uh film
and he's the one that said that it was
kind of like a short film but longer
you know what i mean uh because it
doesn't seem i can see what he's saying
because like i said it's very very
focused on one
concept and on two characters and so
there's not a lot of room
for anything outside of that so you know
in that sense it is very much like a
short film rather than a feature length
and it did seem short to me i mean you
know it was only an hour and 12 minutes
like i said
so i mean if anything about that sounds
appealing to you it's not long
it's like you know it's on shutter you
can watch it and see but like i said
most
people i feel like there was a lot of
people even other horror
uh reviewers that i saw that really
didn't dig it they said it was too
boring it seemed like nothing happened
and they didn't a lot of them didn't
like the end because they're like what
the [ __ ] i didn't understand what that
meant
um you know why was the end so abrupt
and [ __ ] like that which i get that
it didn't bother me like i said it's not
super super brilliant or anything but
i thought it was like for a first film i
thought it was really really good i
thought it was really atmospheric the
acting was great
um and you know so so if you liked a
dark song if you liked after midnight
which i think we
i think that's the movie i'm thinking of
that we reviewed before we reviewed that
a while back
uh and it had it has a little bit of a
pet cemetery type of vibe
to it too not as lurid as that i guess
because it's very
low-key but it's that thematically it's
very similar to that
so if that sounds appealing to you then
maybe you will dig it uh so
check it out on shutter and tell me what
you thought in the comments
and uh you know we'll go from there i
guess so that'll do it for this flickers
of fear i will see you guys
on the next one bye